back in the day we didn't waste photos
we held on to them I said cheese
now we take photos constantly and they
just vanish into the digital ether
selfie with teeth selfie without teeth
oh but wait Polaroid light cameras
haven't faded away they're making a
comeback it's true I've started to see
them pop up at parties and Fujifilm
what of the last instant film camera
makers sold a record 5 million units
last year and expects to sell even more
this year why the surge because it's
really fun and smartphones have taken
away some of the magic of photography so
which one should you get I tested a
bunch of the cameras and a few photo
printers to find out fujifilm makes 8
instant film cameras
8 I tested four and like this Instax
Mini 90 the best while the $70 Instax
Mini 8 is cheaper the $120 mini 90 is
more compact it also has better photo
quality a little LCD to keep count of
film and some fun tricks most of the
Fuji film cameras take Instax Mini film
about the size of a business card the
shots cost about a dollar and take about
four minutes for the full color to
develop if you want wider photos
Fujifilm Instax wide 300 is your best
bet but boy is that thing going to
strain your neck oh and by the way
Outkast was wrong do not shake it like a
Polaroid picture it does nothing and it
can even ruin it ah yes
what about Polaroid it's a good question
it's a digital company now it no longer
makes those classic square prints in
fact another company called The
Impossible Project manufactures the film
for old Polaroid cams and it released
its own camera last week I've taken some
great shots with the awesome-looking
$350 I won but I don't recommend it for
most the film costs about $3 a shot and
a color shot takes 25 minutes to fully
develop where Polaroid does make now is
this Wireless instant photo printer that
pumps out small photos you took with
your phone
it's the best choice for those of us who
want to take digital photos but still
have physical ones to share the $130
polaroid zip printed crisper and
brighter photos than the $130 Fujifilm
printer
that's because Polaroid uses special
Zink paper which contains the colors
Fuji films however produces a film photo
the printers don't have the same novelty
as the cameras but even the act of just
going through your photos and deciding
which one to print will bring back some
of that old-school photography fun smile
we can fight about who gets to keep the
single photo later